la chronique culture comme tous les
mercredis avec johanna soudry oui je ne
suis pas seul en plateau puisque nous
avons avec nos catherine l'outil vous
êtes chef de choeur dans la chorale
croque-notes à guyancourt et vous êtes
également avec nous en plateau benjamin
vous êtes auteur compositeur et
interprète dans le groupe b bly alors
vous êtes de maurepas c'est vous jouerez
également au mois de mars
votre style c'est plutôt pop rock vous
chantez vous écrivez mais vous avez
commencé par la guitare
oui j'ai commencé par la guitare comme
comme tout adolescent qui veut se mettre
à la musique c'est un instrument dont
l'approché est assez rapide on peut on
peut vite sortir des sons qu'il soit bon
ou pas bon et donc en autodidacte la
guitare c'est un bon c'est un bon
instrument
donc vous avez commencé par gratter un
petit peu me disais que c'est plus
facile de soi même composé que d'imiter
donc le problème de la de la reprise
c'est qu'il faut être parfait alors que
si on compose on a de la marge de
manoeuvre pour dire bah ouais là c'est
moi c'est ma griffe et donc vous êtes
venu comme ça la composition vous avez
commencé en solo après vous avez avait
fondé un groupe ça a été un parcours
vous avez connu ces deux grands artistes
comme alain bashung avec qui vous avez
travaillé notamment
non j'ai pas travailler quelle un
bashung on a ouvert pour alain bashung
sur un festival à rambouillet en 2004 je
suis siphonner les côtoyer en tout cas
on l'a pas croisé du tout mais adam et
celui sur la fiche on était à côté
d'alain bashung c'était cool quoi c'est
déjà pas mal sur la piste annoncée très
bien c'est une super opportunité
oui en revanche au niveau du groupe ou
et moi j'ai commencé très vite à vouloir
faire un groupe une fois que j'avais des
compos donc tout de suite on arrivait
dans le groupe qui s'appelait histoire
de l'époque puis au bout d'un moment
et les intentions de chacun étant un peu
divergentes moi j'ai voulu faire un truc
de mon côté un petit peu le côté
nombriliste du groupe faire un projet
solo qui est celui ci donc un album est
sorti en 2009 et un second album qui est
sorti l'année dernière
donc du coup en janvier 2012 voilà c'est
ça intitulé le bonhomme sait levine et
que vous avez fait c'est ce que j'essaie
stressé sur vinyle alors ouais parce
qu'en fait on
non l'idée c'était d'avoir un support en
concert à vendre comme les su comme le
c'est décevant plus en fait est que les
gens téléchargent donc la musique et sur
itunes tout c'est un peu la vie nils un
vrai objet voilà c'est un objet au moins
quand on achète sera en concert donc non
mais le cd dedans pour que les gens
puissent le lire mais en fait on vend le
cd mais dans le package dans le package
cdi à levine et moi combien une combine
platine au passé le principe ce truc
donc dans ce vinyle dans ce cd dans cet
album il ya une chanson c'est reste
encore je propose qu'on découvre un
petit extrait du clip
c'est bien
tu t'étais amoché
enfin si je passais du lot
de rien
le doute encore
je pourrais juillet
si bien être tout le monde d'accord
je n'y fait
et
benjamin sur ce morceau vous êtes avec
deux musiciens alors qui fait quoi
comment ça se passe et vous qui composez
tout en fait
oui moi j'amène fait une idée enfin
maintenant au début sur le premier album
je compose j'avais tout composé sauf les
batteries puisque je sais pas jouer de
batterie mais sur cet album en fait
comme j'ai rencontré des gens super
chouette qui ont travaillé du coup sûr
la sur les arrangements de tous celui ci
j'arrive avec une idée basique d'un
coupé d'un refrain et toute la mouture
de la chanson l'a fait ensemble du début
jusqu'à la fin et vous écrivez en france
est essentiellement voyage pas texte en
anglais parfois je suis une piètre le
français bat non mais c'est bien tant
défaut défendre aussi notre langue
vous avez des influences vous êtes fan
de certains musiciens groupes français
ou ouais moi j'ai beaucoup aimé alain
bashung pour le 17 est intéressant
eiffel aussi peut-être parce que vous
avez fait la première partie des faits
oui en mai dernier on a fait faire
c'était cool
je dis souvent c'était cool mais ça va
finir par vous croire non mais fait l'on
a fait on a fait deportivo ce genre de
choses groupe local aussi et vous allez
rejouer en première partie des faits
justement le jeudi 24 janvier à la clé
c'est une salle à saint germain en laye
épine dorsale
ouais vous connaissez déjà cette salle
ben moi j'y avais joué en 2004 en
première partie de cali avec l'autre
groupe
on y rejoue avec eiffel donc la nouvelle
salle à saint germain qui est superbe et
vous jouerez aussi chez vous amour pot
café de la plage qui lors de la soirée
d'ouverture de la nouvelle salle et ça
sera en mars début mars que samedi de
mars
oui mais ouvrez donc ils font chaque
année font le festival chaud l'hiver
cette année le fin dans leurs nouveaux
locaux et c'est donc le groupe du nom d
un groupe du cobalt
on a enregistré là-bas l'album est
d'accord voulait enregistrer cobalt des
corses et des studios voilà et nous les
panneaux barennes il nous est donc quand
il nous demande un truc en hiver alors
peut-être on peut rappeler wilfried
quelques dates aussi de l'agenda alors
samedi donc samedi qu'un samedi qui
vient
nous pouvons vous conseiller d'aller ali
mais là le père noël est un rockeur
c'est un groupe avec los tres puntos
aussi il y aura j'abuse corbas et
scratch voilà donc et oui c'est comme ça
ça sympa donc on entrait en fête
permettra d'offrir un jouet neuf d'une
valeur de 8 euros
et puis le lendemain dimanche 16
décembre à 15 heures à la mjc de la
celle saint cloud vous pourrez retrouver
oldelaf qu'on connaît bien aussi ici
avec son spectacle bête et méchant c'est
un spectacle pour jeune public
cinar question pour l'inviter vous allez
rester en plateau avec nous mais b bly
c'est là c'est la compression de mon nom
de famille de mon prénom et nom de
famille c'est pas parce que prénom là
c'est benjamin b et billel c'est oublié
c'est le meilleur ça lasse on va essayer
de percer ce mystère pour les
rétrojaïres de disques ont bien souffert
mari je sais pas si je vais peut-être
pas le dire achetez le vinyle et vous le
verrez écrit en bas voilà alors pour moi
ça s'appelle je propose de rester un peu
dans l'univers de la musique et d'y
ajouter de l'acrobatie du cirque et du
théâtre
nous avons découvert un spectacle un
conte même intitulé un conte
acrobatiquement musicale je vous propose
tous types de découvrir quelques
extraits nous avons rencontré l'auteur
et la metteur en scène
le grand public l'a découvert dans la
comédie musicale les dix commandements
de pascal obispo le chanteur pablo
villafranca se produit aujourd'hui dans
un spectacle à dimension humaine
il prête sa voix à la compagnie
aventurine pour un con alliant danse
théâtre chant et cirque
sur scène ils sont douze artistes ou
l'appellation qu'on lui a donné ses
comptes acrobatiquement musicale est ce
effectivement pluridisciplinaire ça
mélange le chant le théâtre les arts du
cirque la magie la danse
c'est l'histoire d'adrien qui est un
ancien clown devenu sdf parce qu'il
s'est passé un drame dans sa vie et qui
en fait
parce qu'il ya un cirque il s'installe à
côté de lui va petit à petit revenir
vers sa vie d'avant donc c'est toute
l'histoire et tout le cheminement du
justement un peu le paradoxe entre le
clown qui est un personnage qui fait
plutôt rire qui inspire confiance le
côté très positif de ce personnage et le
personnage du sdf qui lui dans
l'inconscient collectif à quelque chose
à bord un couple négation l'histoire
originale de ce conte drôle et touchant
et signer notre bettina mari auteur pour
la télévision elle présente
quotidiennement une émission de jeunesse
sur le câble au théâtre elle met en
scène des artistes qui donnent naissance
à ses textes
moi je suis vraiment dans la direction
d'acteurs dans l'intention serra et il
ya la chorégraphie à côté après le but
c'est de de tout mettre ensemble nous
tous rassemblés pour justement avoir un
spectacle fluide en fait ce qu'on voit
un ensemble et je pense que c'est ça qui
sort du lot en ce moment c'est ce côté
magique grand sens du terme ça c'est le
côté spectacle en fait il n'y a pas pas
une pièce de théâtre ou du chant ou
danser on voit un spectacle entier quoi
pour découvrir
adrien où la vie en équilibre trois
dates à retenir les 11 12 et 19 janvier
à la salle blanche de castille à poissy
donc un joli spectacle pour noël à
découvrir en famille catherine lautier
vous êtes chef de choeur dans l'accord à
guyancourt toise croque notes et
justement vous allez pour noël donné un
concert en l'église saint victor dans le
centre-ville de guyancourt vous même
vous êtes choriste depuis onze ans au
sein de cette chorale est là vous êtes
maintenant chef de choeur vous êtes
devenu chef de choeur comment vous avez
accueilli ce nouveau rôle ça vous plaît
ah oui vraiment ça me plaît beaucoup en
fait c'était c'était pas prévu et puis
c'est une opportunité que j'ai saisi
puisque notre chef de choeur devant
dernier
un sou été arrêté et donc voilà je suis
parti dans l'aventuré je regrette
absolument pas parce que c'est vraiment
une expérience super intéressante et
donc comme je suis depuis 11 ans dans
cette chorale je connais tout le monde
il ya quand même du roulement des gens
qui partageaient un des nouveaux qui
arrivent mais il ya quand même un noyau
dur on va dire et en fait ce sont des
gens très agréables qui bosse bien et on
s'amuse bien il ya une super ambiance
donc voilà donc ça se passe très bien
tous plus tôt pour vous de les connaître
parce que parfois ou tout à fait rire
les gens vont mourir leader chez
salariales sont disciplinés nous plus ou
moins certains plus que l'autre mais non
mais ça se passe très bien et est là
donc on prépare notre concert qui est
samedi soir à l'église saint victor à
guyancourt 20h30 c'est une tradition ces
enceintes de la chorale croque notes de
chanter pour noël oui on l'a on l'a
pratiquement fait tous les ans en effet
et là on fait vraiment un véritable
concert de noël donc c'est que des
chants de noël que tout le monde connaît
qu'on entend partout harmonisé à quatre
voies bien sûr on est accompagné par une
pianiste
il y raconte en mer comme morceau qu'on
va pouvoir retrouver alors d'être est
connu c'est
les anges dans nos campagnes il est né
divine enfants mais tous à harmoniser de
manière très agréable
il y a
e
on finit aussi par le parrain extraits
du messie de haendel donc l'alléluia
parce qu'on travaille on va travailler
cette oeuvre pour le mois de juin offre
un deuxième cancer pour l'année donc
c'était un petit peu en avance de phase
voilà il vous chante aussi dans d'autres
langues pas quel français
oui donc son des chants de noël en
français anglais allemand espagnol
qu'est ce qui vous a donné envie
justement de vous ouvrir comme ça aussi
c'est la sicile à l'harmonisation de
chaque morceau qui qui est vraiment très
sympathique et qui donne envie de les
chanter
vous maîtrisez sa chacune de celles on
and on a pas du tout de savoir une
langue pour chanter avec quoi donc
moi j'ai chanté en russie champion
slovaque qui chantait en tchèque
je comprenais rien on leur remet la mise
et vous chantez pas chanté par en
anglais du tour voyez pas besoin de
maîtriser la langue pour chantant mais
alors pas du tout avec un petit peu de
d'écouter puis quelques personnes un peu
expérimentés qui nous disent comment
prononcer et on arrive à chanter plein
de choses quoi en général les gens qui
ont l'oreille musicale arrive plus
facilement à voir les accents au
peut-être ou une question d'oreille et
d'imitations aussi donc les prochains
concerts on l'a dit à noël dont enfin le
concert de noël de samedi 15 donc ce
samedi
fm à 20h30 et puis vous nous parlez
aussi de juin voilà un peu plus tard le
15 juin le samedi 15 juin pareil à
l'église saint victor
on a prévu de faire l'euro que la
plupart des choeurs du messie de haendel
vous recrutez c'est une chorale qui
recrutent on recrute bien sûr
régulièrement on a des nouveaux on passe
à la halle aux forums des associations
mois de septembre à guyancourt
et puis voilà un recruteur cherche
principalement des pupitres d'hommes
masqués mi-journée quand facile de
respirer
vous allez pouvoir rejoindre la chorale
pour le plaisir mais bon là on a un bon
groupe d'hommes qui sont vraiment bien
et mais bon si on a motivé qui
connaissent la musique
il n'y a pas de problème ils peuvent ils
peuvent nous contacter vous êtes combien
de choristes en tout une quarantaine
si on va avoir des informations racheter
les places aux autres c'est sur place
grillades
il ya une site internet et puis voilà on
a mis des affiches un peu partout dans
la ville
l'envoi le site internet la qui
s'affiche à d'accord or voilà que
l'information soit la copie notre point
free.fr on parlait tout à l'heure de
votre registre on parle de ses chants
traditionnels aussi pour la période de
noël est ce que vous vous ouvrez aussi
sur un registre le plus moderne de
choses diverses et variées par exemple
par rapport à l'invité on avait tout à
l'heure sur ce plateau
oui nos brevets par enfin que vous aviez
qui vous a quand même bien c'est fini
merci beaucoup en fait non la chorale
est en fait une chorale plus classiques
on ne fait pas de variétés bon temps en
temps faire du gospel bon voilà on fait
des choses un petit peu c'est par compte
par mois séparent
non c'est ceinture était comme ça bon on
peut éventuellement évoluer mais voilà
je pense que la plupart des choristes
sont vraiment passionnés plus de
classique lyrique
les choeurs d'opéra des oeuvres ou bien
connu mozart beethoven
vous arrivez à le dis à tous à découvrir
pendant la période de noël en apparaît
tout à l'heure il ya plein d'autres
choses aussi à faire justement à l'
approche de noël
le lot quelques dates whip le petit
agenda alors pouvez par exemple vous
rendre à magny les hameaux qui propose
son parvis en fait c'est samedi le 15
décembre de 15 heures à 18 heures là
vous aurez plusieurs ateliers avec un
spectacle de rue est aussi un feu
d'artifice pour clore cette journée est
toujours à l'hôtel de ville de magny les
hameaux une exposition de marionnettes
est à découvrir jusqu'au 20 décembre
ce sont les marionnettes de jeanne une
artiste plasticienne qui a créé des
marionnettes à partir de matériaux de
récupération
c'est assez joli et puis on va rester
dans le champ avec une autre chorale
plutôt gospel celle-ci donc 60 choristes
de la chorale billancourt toi également
50 un gospel se produiront à l'école de
musique et de danse de trappes à 20h30
donc samedi 15
on va rester à trappes pour les féeries
cette fois ci ça s'est un peu plus tard
c'est le samedi 22 décembre
ça commence à 14 heures jusqu'à 19
heures c'est une fête vraiment pour les
enfants où ils pourront et bien s'amuser
dans des ateliers de création découvrir
des spectacles et des animations
et puis toujours pour les enfants à
voisins le bretonneux ça se passe
mercredi prochain à 16h voilà les
enfants pourront rencontrer le père noël
et oui il travaille qu un mois par an
donc ceux qui n'ont pas le câble sata
mais voilà si vous dites sales pas même
en attendant ils travaillent toute
l'année
le père noël est très gentil est
vraiment un voisin il propose de faire
des photos qui seront prêts mis sur le
site internet de la ville et des bonbons
si c'est plutôt sympa ça allez on
revient donc samedi à montigné avec une
autre ambiance
une ambiance créole cette fois ci
l'association culture et tradition
d'outre-mer vous propose de chanter noël
un noël antillais voilà c'est à 18
heures jusqu'à minuit
et puis on finit à la verrière mercredi
prochain avec un autre concert
décidément les élèves de la maison de la
musique vous invitent à leur concert de
noël spécial
deux bandes originales de films à la
musique de films plutôt plutôt sympa
agenda complet agenda culture que vous
pouvez aussi retrouver sur notre site
internet comme l'ensemble de nos
séquences dès demain matin quelques
informations musique wii music toujours
star academy forcément c'est la neuvième
saison vous le savez les élèves sont
installés dans le château de la jeunesse
à châteaufort et cette année bien deux
candidats sont yvelinois alors une fille
seven in alors là je vois sur les images
on voit le gars sont en vigueur sont
donc ces sidoine voilà il a 25 ans il
est arrivé en région parisienne il ya
trois ans il ya rejoint sa petite amie
laetitia qui elle habite à versailles et
il est habitué des casting de la star
ac' puisque malheureusement il en a fait
plusieurs à chaque fois il a été recalé
mais sa persévérance a fini par payer
puisqu'il a intégré cette année le
château de châteaufort pour la nouvelle
saison
et puis la jeune fille qu'on va voir
juste après elle s'appelle vanina a
fallu 20 27 les banques disent que c'est
parce que toute la journée j'ai dans la
tête et donc elle a commencé la musique
à deux ans voilà c'est ça quand même
assez tôt elle est originaire de corse
on la voit l'image et elle est montée en
région parisienne elle vit désormais à
versailles elle aussi donc deux
versaillais
après une prépa biochimie elle a décidé
de renoncer à son avenir de chercheuse
pour se consacrer à sa passion la
musique et lors du premier prime jeudi
et bien elle a interprété la chanson
diam's de rihanna c'était le point star
ac de la semaine merci arrive sur canal
merci à nous deux invités qui sont venus
sur ce plateau nous parler de leur
actualité respectives elles la troupe du
crâne à 30 ans et du théâtre on va en
parler dans quelques minutes pour
l'instant une opération de
sensibilisation bucco dentaire dans
cette école de classe de cp la de
trappes mais mt dans parlons c'est son
nom elle est portée par la caisse
primaire d'assurance maladie
jabra
apprendre à bien se brosser les dents
savoir aussi le vocabulaire dentaire
dans de l'aide en définitive ou dans du
fond on a toujours commencé à nettoyer
et comme on va commencer par le haut
ensuite ça va descendre la caisse
primaire d'assurance maladie a donc
lancé il ya sept ans l'opération est
menée dans cette année cette animation
concerne douze classes de cp de la ville
de trappes comme ici à l'école jean macé
et la leçon retenue les dénombrer fait
quoi comment se brossait déjà hélas bien
je pense qu'il a il a amélioré ce qu'il
avait déjà et pour les bamboo il faut
pas trop manger autres le sont passées
auprès des enfants et de leurs parents
une brosse à dents cela ne se prêtent
pas et il faut éviter les boissons
sucrées le soir car l'ennemi à chasser
c'est bien à cary quand on les écoute
c'est vrai pour eux se détachent on
passe par toutes les couleurs
ils n'ont vraiment pas conscience qu'il
s'agit d'un trou et que ça devienne
réellement une dent et qu'on garde ça
pas toute sa vie ce dispositif de
sensibilisation dans les classes
s'accompagne d'une opération de
prévention gratuite tous les jeunes âgés
de 6 9 12 15 et 18 ans peuvent
bénéficier d'un examen de prévention
gratuit et des soins consécutifs
nécessaire une vraie réalité
80 % des enfants de 6 ans ne consultent
pas de chirurgien dentiste et 60% des
enfants issus de familles en difficulté
présentent des problèmes dentaires